Nikon is G30 is this the camera for
Content creators to pick up out there
let's talk about this I've had this
camera in my hands for the past month
I've been using it for a number of
projects for my social media account
because primarily we shoot a lot of
video for our social media these days
and there are many things I liked about
the z30 and a couple things I wish were
improved and we'll get into those in
just a bit but overall the first thing
that stood out to me was the build
quality and the ergonomics and the
button layout and the dials Everything
feels really well made good quality
doesn't feel like Nikon like chimpers
try to save money because it's a cheaper
camera no the ergonomics feel great I
have larger hands and it feels really
good in the hand uh the buttons the
dials Everything feels as it should be
like other Nikon Z cameras out there so
I was pleasantly surprised by that and I
really appreciated that attention to
detail especially on a camera that's
priced far less than their other Z
camera systems out there another thing I
liked was the video quality out of this
thing I have to say the image quality
was really good of course you get 4k 30
you know full width of the sensor it's
an aps-c sensor we know that but still
you compare this with any Z mount lens
out there from a 24 to 70 F 2.8 to an
806.3 you could have a field day and you
can also adapt older lenses to this as
well and I really like that the image I
was getting out of this it was nice
sometimes you have to mix and match with
other camera systems out there and I use
my smartphone a lot to record videos we
all do I'm using the iPhone 13 Pro Max
and I'm noticed noticing that the image
quality in terms of color science is
almost the same so there are times where
I was mixing and matching footage and
nobody could tell the difference that I
was using a different camera and I was
asking people do you know what I was
using here and they couldn't tell which
is really good because sometimes we're
going to need to use other equipment
we've not one camera is going to do
everything for us but the fact that you
can mix and match footage and it's pairs
seamlessly is really really cool also I
like the tally light it's a small thing
it's a very small thing but I like it
I'm using the z9 right now to record and
this camera is phenomenal for a video we
all know that but there is no tally
light I wish there was one but it's not
there maybe they can add into a firmware
update who knows but that is a nice
attribute because so there have been
times we've all been there admitted
where we recorded or we thought we
recorded a great long talking segment
only to find out
either your card was filled up
or you didn't press record correctly
oh were we recording
it's happened to all of us so having a
tally light is a really good feature
especially when your display doesn't
flip out or rotate but this one does as
well which is also a nice attribute so
you want to record in landscape mode
16x9 there is a there's the display for
you you want to flip it vertically which
you can do with a small raid tripod grip
the display is there so you can see your
framing I love this and what's cool what
Nikon did with this is they also
simplified the display so when you flip
out and it faces you you don't get all
that information there now if you want
that information you can turn that on
but that's a little bit tricky to find
that setting it took me a while to
figure that out which we'll talk about
in just a bit in terms of menu
functionalities but outside of that
there's a lot of thought that came into
this camera system for Content creators
also in terms of the internal mic is
actually not that bad I was pleasantly
surprised now I tend to use more
professional mic setups because I like
really good audio but if you don't have
a mic system right now and you need some
audio and a pinch you'll be pleasantly
surprised with the audio that comes out
of this camera you're actually hearing
the audio from the camera right now to
get an idea of how it sounds we got the
dead cuts on it yeah so far so good a
lot of exposure is really good on this
we're doing 4K 30 full frame and uh yeah
no crop we're using the 16 to 50 lens
and yeah this is a great lens for
vlogging another thing that I really
liked about using the system was
actually this small grip handheld grip
that they make it's designed to use with
the remote controls you can control the
camera via Bluetooth I like this thing a
lot first and foremost it's great you
want to sit on a table you want to
record yourself talking it's there if
you want to go into vertical mode you
want to choose something for Instagram
or Facebook or Tick Tock you can swivel
it and go portrait mode on that no
issues at all the Bluetooth
functionality through the remote control
works relatively well again you have to
wake up the controller every time you
use it it doesn't automatically just
turn on when you turn on the camera it's
a small thing but it's it's part and
parcel with using these kind of this
technology but one thing I liked it's a
lot easier to sync up that Bluetooth or
controller versus what Sony does with
their systems which is like a convoluted
mess this is relatively easy to do and
you can pretty much figure it out in a
couple minutes and you're good to go but
that's pretty much my thoughts of the
z30 in a nutshell it's a really good
content creators tool but there are some
things to talk about the menu system on
this is a little bit perplexed for a
simplified camera Nikon is known to put
a lot of things in their camera system
the kitchen sinks sometimes case in
point the z9 it's awesome you can do so
many things with their cameras so many
settings are available to you however if
you're coming from a smartphone into a
camera like this you may be a little bit
overwhelmed by all the settings and how
to set things up I would recommend
having someone walk you through that
that's my personal opinion but it'd be
nice if Nikon created a simplified menu
for Content creators that just want to
or just the average person that doesn't
want to dig deep into menus and just
goes look I just want to press record I
want to record something I want good
image quality I want that yes you can
put it on Automotive you can do most of
those things but it'd be great to have
that that simplified menu inside the
camera another thing image stabilization
inside the camera now there are some
lenses that you're going to get VR with
and yes there is electronic uh vibration
reduction or vrs they call it for Nikon
which is image stabilization but it's
not the same as in body stabilization
this camera is small it is lightweight
and you are going to get some camera
Shake now it's not a deal breaker if you
know how to manage that but if you're
new to this you might go whoa my footage
is really shaky so you're gonna have to
take your time with this you're gonna
have to slow down a little bit so
hopefully in the next version of the z30
if they make another one that they would
put in body stabilization inside of it
that would be fantastic talking about
the evm for a second I like an evf I'm a
traditionalist there are times where the
evf comes in handy case in point if I'm
shooting outside it's bright daylight
that display it is bright but sometimes
you don't get to see the details and
having an evf where you can actually
just look in and sell and close you can
actually see if the exposure is correct
that the focusing is working
it really does help sometimes that's
what the zfc might come into play for
some of you out there the zfc is
primarily designed for photography with
video functionality too and of course is
reminiscent let's say I got the fm3a
here looks sort of like that
and then kind of like your your F3 here
it's got that retro Vibe that's what the
zfc is all about but the z30 is more for
video but yeah yeah sometimes having an
evf does come in handy so teach their
own but outside of that man I did like
the z30 I think Nikon did a great job
with this I'm I'm excited to see where
they go with this platform I think the
lenses are not bad the kit lenses they
will do the job but they have some
really great lenses out there if you
want to adapt to them and you're going
to get a wide variety as I mentioned
earlier of lenses that are going to be
some beautiful depth of field you're
gonna get some really good character out
of a lens if you want to go older on it
there's so many options you can play
with with the z30 to really make it your
primary content creators tool if this is
the camera you want to opt for anyway
but if you want to go for let's say 4K
120 you want full frame that's another
camera system altogether but at this
price point Nikon has done a fantastic
job anyway those are my thoughts on the
z30 let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below if you like this
video check out more of our reviews
right here